أنت تسمي الوضع هنا غزوًا
لدولة نووية أمة ذات
طاقة نووية غير مسبوقة ، كيف
حسنًا من ناحية واحدة أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، من
الجيد جدًا التحدث إليك ، شكرًا لكونك
على اتصال بهذه اللحظات الصعبة
للعالم وبالطبع IEA  تشارك بشكل كامل
في هذا الوضع بسبب ولايتنا ،
ودورنا التقني في ضمان
سلامة وأمن المنشآت النووية في
جميع أنحاء العالم في هذه
الحالة ، ما يجعلها غير مسبوقة هي
أن هذه هي المرة الأولى
في فترة ما بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية.  تاريخنا أن
لدينا عملية عسكرية كاملة
وسط
عدد لا بأس به من عدد كبير من
المنشآت النووية بما في ذلك
المفاعلات النووية أربعة مواقع كبيرة مع 15
مفاعلًا نوويًا توفر
أقل من
من الكهرباء التي يتم إنتاجها
واستهلاكها في أوكرانيا ومنشآت أخرى
بما في ذلك  بالطبع الأيقونة إذا جاز لي أن
أسميها
هكذا لأنها أصبحت رمزًا عالميًا أه
تشيرنوبيل وهو مكان حيث يوجد موقع
عملية تفكيك
جارية لذلك كل هذه الأمور
تحدث وطبعا أه هناك
دائما خطر
نشاط عسكري يمكن أن يؤثر على
هذه المواقع أو أنه قد يكون هناك بعض
الانقطاع
أو بعض الانقطاع في
التشغيل العادي لأي من هذه المنشآت
التي  قد ينتج
عنه مشكلة أو وقوع حادث
ولهذا أسميته غير
مسبوق ولهذا السبب نحن منخرطون
ونعمل أه لمحاولة
الحفاظ على سلامة وأمن
هذه الأماكن نحن نعمل بالطبع
مع مواطننا الأوكراني  نظرائي أنا على
اتصال دائم دائم مع
المنظم النووي لأوكرانيا مع
مشغلي الشركة إذا كنت تريد
أن تمتلك
هذه المفاعلات النووية وتشغلها ،
فإننا نتبادل المعلومات ، فنحن
نقدم لهم بعض النصائح
والدعم الفني وكما
ذكرت بحق لديهم
طلبت
المزيد من المساعدة وبالطبع أنا
أعمل على طرائق ذلك
التي يمكنك أن تتخيلها في curren
الظروف ليست
بالأمر السهل ولكننا سنحاول
تقديم هذه المساعدة بالتأكيد